we were meant for this Nathan
[Music]
you me together we were destined for
something great
[Music]
for those who prove worthy paradise
awaits took a long time for him to get
out of this game he's meant for this
last I checked we're all a bunch of
thieves digging around what we shouldn't
turn we're not on the same side yeah
I'm a man of fortune and I'm a seek my
fortune so are you ready to seek your
fortune
murder the artifact
I made a promise that I was done with
this life how long we been chasing this
thing long time really long time just
you and me no offense to these guys they
don't get it if you're done lying to me
then you should stop run to yourself
biggest pirate treasure of all time is
within our grasp look nate I'm gonna
make you a one-time offer drop
everything
go home
live your life or we can just end it
right here who's gotta pay the other way
I need you on this one
[Music]
ever wonder like different choices how
we might ended up no I like the hand
we've been done
those things